hey it's Evan and I believe it's
important to thank the people who are
making a difference in your business and
your life because being an entrepreneur
is hard and we all have battles to fight
and it's the people around us who helped
us get over everything you can't do it
yourself and sometimes it's nice just to
sit back and think about the people
who've helped you along your way and
send them a nice thank you to make them
feel good and to make you feel good and
grateful for their help and their
friendship so today i want to thank
Shawn Moffitt now Shawn and I first met
at a coffee shop that was a friend of
mine it was his coffee shop that she had
called little nicky's and it got run
into by a bus and imagine you know
running the business is hard enough
you've got this bus that comes into your
building and you've got to close down
and I felt so bad for this coffee shop
that i sent an email to my newsletter
list and said hey I'd like to support
this entrepreneur friend of mine
everybody in Toronto if you're here
let's all meet up a little nicky's when
they open up again and you know this
time this day and we'll go support them
and surprise them and so we did and we
kind of filled the coffee shop and Shawn
was one of the people who came out and
the one of the things that always
impressed me about sean is how he's
really giving and caring and likes to
help other people and so he came out to
help the owner of little nicky's and to
meet me and we talked business for a
little bit and from there we met up a
couple times and one of the things I'm
most grateful to shine about is he
introduced me to my now agent and he is
at the same agency that I'm at and we
came up with a few ideas on how to work
together and in that discussion he said
well this idea came from my agent and
I've never heard of an agent for
business people for for you know thought
leaders you think of agents for for
baseball players and athletes not kind
of stuff but there's an agent for
business people and thought leaders and
so he set up an introduction and I ended
up becoming I guess on the roster and a
lot of things have happened since then I
got my radio show working on a book deal
the videos
got a lot better I've gotten some great
coaching and that wouldn't have happened
without the introduction from Shawn and
again he was just trying to help out and
try to help a fellow entrepreneur and
you know he knows about the struggles of
running the business and so Sean I
really appreciate that all the all the
help you've given me especially in the
past year or so and I wanted to make
this video to say thank you so you know
for everybody watching there's somebody
in your life who has helped you with
your business get to where it is even if
it's just supporting you and saying hey
I believe in you and this is important
work that you're doing take some time
today to thank them it doesn't have to
be a video it can't be an email it can
be a handwritten note you can you know
get them a gift card but it doesn't have
to be something that you're spending a
lot of money on just just show them that
you care about them that you appreciate
them feel the gratitude it'll make you
feel better it'll make them feel better
and everybody will have a great day so
thanks for watching if you guys like
this video give it a thumbs up below you
have a question a comment leave it below
in the comments I make a video response
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon